levani didn't have much time to think
about it after yesterday's roller
coaster against Fabiano but what was the
strategy going into today's match
um try to avoid what happened yesterday
yesterday was a bit too crazy for your
taste yeah
and tell us about the first game because
that's when you took full Reigns of this
match
yeah so I knew there is this idea with
the pawn sacrifice
but honestly today I think I spent Maybe
at least two hours walking around the
park I was I thought to myself I
shouldn't really prepare I just need to
you know I'm not for sure so
I mean of course black can play like
this and there's nothing wrong with it
but white has no risk so it's type of a
play I wanted to get in a type of a
technical play and then yeah I thought
this was more or less logical
uh
uh I thought 92 was a good move because
I'm trying this Knight C4
or Knight B3 things you know because
night doesn't really belong to E4 yeah
yeah it can get kicked away with that
fight yeah things like that I mean in
this type of
things if you manage to restrict the
monster on V7 then you'll be better but
of course it's not that easy and that
felt like it was the battle for a very
long time right he was trying to open
things up with G5 H5
were you getting worried at this point
that this monster as you painted it
might actually get open yeah well I
calculated here but you can never be
sure I I was I was not really sure I
thought Bishop H6 was not the right move
I thought Bishop G7 was more precise I
thought black has a full compensation
because Knight C1 rookie 6
and I has this Rook H6 I I will be
forced to play Bishop before anyway and
then he can just play Rook G6 c62 Queen
H3 this type of things you know
yeah he won't let me get out once I get
all got out I thought that I got some
Chances with the Knight on G3 this yes
yeah although later I think I almost
planted my night at 95 at some point at
what point uh well when uh yeah when we
did this G3 Bishop is seven rookie two
can get fate yeah my first intention was
to play something like
I mean I wanted to play Bishop somewhere
like Bishop E5 but then I saw Bishop F3
Rook G5 and
yeah H2 and Rook G5 yeah yeah this would
have been horrendous yeah and uh so I
thought okay I gotta stay focused
position is droveish of course after
Bishop B5
uh I thought he had this rookie sixth
move
and what about wait a minute what about
negative six this move now you have
Knight F6 okay okay Knight to D7 you
cannot touch this yeah yeah this is my
chippo well prepared
yeah I was actually
yeah instead of Bishop G5 I mean he was
down on time but I think he has rookie 6
here
and let's see and black is oh yeah my
goodness yeah yeah I actually wanted
this so now if you take the problem is
you take the yeah you take take and even
the night is nothing so rukish 2 was
probably a blunder or
you know yeah yeah here's somewhere I
started blundering yeah I felt it
that's a difficult move to make right
yeah I knew already I've missed my
chances here but uh so Bishop E5 was
kind of I thought it's a clever idea but
then I saw rookie six my God yeah rookie
six was a big one yeah so I got really
lucky here and here is probably a draw
actually
I thought black is so active he
shouldn't be losing this
but you still managed to create more and
more problems for your opponent yeah he
was done on time so yeah he's trying to
utilize that did you feel like this is
the factor that made the most difference
just the fact that he wasn't able to
catch up on time with you
huh maybe maybe definitely if they had
more time he would see rookie six well
during the finals right now uh were you
watching the finals of the elimination
bracket oh yeah I'm in uh were you
watching this game between Wesley and
Hikaru and who do you expect to join you
I don't really care I'm
I'm survived yesterday so now all of
this is just a bonus yes guys join the
conversation yeah first of all
congratulations for moving on Lavon I'd
like to turn your attention to the game
between Alice Lee and Arena Crush you're
a great end game player as he throws him
a bone uh tell us uh what you feel is
the proper result in this particular
Rook ending uh Christian could you put
it on your board please so that uh Lavon
can see the current position yes okay
well it looks rather unpleasant here the
king comes to H5 and then
uh then The Rook will enter on the G
file I mean
I mean it's very unpleasant for white so
this should be the black king G6 King H5
try to keep the king to the defense of
those squares yeah because if you bring
the king to the other side I'll bring
mine to the other side yes and then I'll
get rugby three Rook H3 yeah
and then you have some problems so you
have to really quickly uh
get to this wish that she just played
King to G6 and by the way Alice is only
yeah with two minutes on her clock okay
so you get your idea with King H5 yeah
what happens here
this is a big problem I cannot go work
through it before because of A5 and my
root gets pretty much trapped
um
so I stay I wait all right I give you a
check
let's say I stay close to my F Pawn all
right now I can play Rook d8 or I can
also
try to enter from yeah King H4 is
actually not that stupid
he's a natural born commentator
Bachelor foreign commentator he's
looking for a job I can see you oh you
talk too much yes sir I'll take your
joke be careful
nice okay well thank you for thank you
for that uh
I wanted to get your Insight I liked
what you're saying King H5 Rook G8 for
arena and Alice with a minute on her
clock is in trouble again uh Lavon thank
you very much for taking my job
anytime we've got a warm seat now I
admire you yesterday I really admire
that you can talk I mean and make sense
for so many hours in a row I mean I
cannot do that so I would never dream of
taking your job not at all good luck in
the next uh next match it's going to be
very exciting one tomorrow and uh one
minute for Alice did I hear you say that
she's under oh